plusieurs commerçants doivent se
réinventer pour contrer les effets de la
coved 19 native touch une entreprise qui
est spécialisée dans le marketing et la
publicité propose à ses clients d'offrir
du contenu sur les appareils mobiles
en réalité augmentée c'est ce qu'a fait
en trop que l'entreprise de lunettes
clearly en misant sur la publicité pour
relancer ses ventes en ligne
on va en parler avec un genre à jamais
les cofondatrices de native touch
entreprises donc de teknologik
publicitaire mobile qui est basée à
montréal
bonsoir madame ajam bonsoir
expliquez-nous d'abord comment ça
fonctionne votre technologie donc cette
technologie de réalité augmentée on vous
de l'offrir à crédit et que ses dents
temps c'est qu'on se placer un objet sur
le visage le cou et la tête par exemple
on peut essayer du maquillage ou des
montures de lunettes concasseur avec la
canton de creully
on postule essayer de placer un objet
dans notre environnement quand par
exemple un mode et on travaille
couramment sur la possibilité d'été des
vêtements sont le corps dans le futur
c'est quelque chose d'autre à venir
aussi on se place du point de vue du
consommateur là où nos téléspectateurs
est-ce que c'est efficace est ce que
c'est aussi efficace que d'essayer
physiquement la lunette ou le vêtement
mais la base c'est que depuis la
pandémie on essaie de voir ce qu'on peut
faire différemment et aussi des
commerces qui ne sont qu electronic donc
noté le choix que d'essayer de voir
comment combler le vide de ne pas
pouvoir aller en magasin était quelque
chose
donc c'est vraiment bien de pouvoir
avoir accès à quelque chose qui aide à
combler ce vide entre comparativement à
simplement acheté cliquer et acheter se
faire livrer un produit en ligne
on a déjà une petite idée de ce que ça
peut avoir l'air sur nous est ce que les
consommateurs retourne - les articles
dans ce contexte là qu'ils ont commandés
ça doit certainement aidé beaucoup parce
qu'au moins tu as une idée de de
croissance sur ce point
donc je crois que ça aiderait mais on a
tant la plupart des commerçants pointent
quant à la petite de bons devant
programme de retour donc les gens
ashtiani est ce que pour du point de vue
là du commerçant est ce que ça aide à
concrétiser des ventes souvent des
consommateurs se promène en ligne voit
certains articles qui les intéressent
mais ne passe pas à l'achat est ce que
par exemple dans le cas de cleo lee est
ce que ça permet vraiment d'augmenter
les ventes
oui parce que je crois que l'on vit dans
une époque pour les consommateurs en
fins de recherche
avant d'acheter et il la réalité
augmentée aide ce processus de recherche
donc ça vient aider lé commerce
électronique en temps et aussi les les
ventes en magasin donc ça fait vraiment
le processus de recherche
c'est une technologie on a l'impression
qu'ils se répand qui existaient il ya un
certain temps qui est adoptée de plus en
plus il ya même le cabinet gartner qui
dit d'ici la fin de l'année 100 millions
de consommateurs dans le monde vont
avoir magasiné au moins une fois en
ligne avec la réalité augmentée est ce
que vous croyez qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de potentiel pour la croissance comme ça
a certainement n'est vraiment au début
de l'augmenter de la réalité augmentée
puis ce qui est nouveau concept nouveau
maintenant fait que on le fait dans le
contexte d'une publicité donc donc
quelqu'un est en train de lire un
article voix ou en publicité et qui
dessus sans même quitter l'application
de nouvelles ventes qui te suivent à
essayer les dix ans montures de lunettes
dans ce café puis s'il est intéressé
continue dans le site d'études d'acheter
au défi d'aller trouver un magasin
physique et il retourne à son article
donc ça pas besoin d'aller aussi
éprouvant de cinq ans ce soit sur tourne
à la fête n'a fait que c'est une
expérience bien meilleur et c'est juste
aider le consommateur à pouvoir vous
accrocher certainement un plus grand
bassin de consommateurs de cette manière
là est ce qui est beaucoup de demande
madame à jamais
des commerçants des clients existants
potentiel sans croissance votre
entreprise
oui définitivement une demande accrue
depuis le lancement de ce produit qui
est définitivement accélérée par les
restrictions de ventes au détail causés
par la famille oui vous avez des
concurrents belges en fait parce qu'il
ya d'autres entreprises qui offrent des
services similaires je pense à ikea qui
a déjà proposé justement de déguiser
notre salon sephora offre justement un
maquillage virtuel
est-ce que vous avez des concurrents qui
offre des technologies de réalité
augmentée comme ça elle a été augmenté
comme vous l'avez vous n'y allez là
depuis des vanniers qui est nouveau dans
notre classe c'est l'application ces
technologies dans le contexte
publicitaire
donc à partir du public est resté dans
le contexte publicitaire et pouvoir
essayer toutes les choses sans même
aller au ticket afin d'aller au site de
sephora
donc ça ne fait même trouvé avec du
palais sur le strip essayer les montures
m qu'ils fassent des choix est inutile
d'avoir un client aller sur le site
directement
donc j'essaie de combler ce vide en les
gardant sur la publicité pour qu'ils
puissent retourner à ce qu'il est en
train de faire que ce soit de jouer à un
jeu de donner un article où on regarde
une brouille vous êtes une entreprise
publicité chez native touch ça n'a pas
dû être facile au printemps les dépenses
de publicité ont reculé une serment oui
c'est certain avec que la pandémie au
début ce moment tout le marketing est un
défi au début parce que on ne savait pas
trop ce qu'il a fait mais depuis
quelques mois ça fait sale a bien
augmenté les commerçants veulent
augmenter leur chiffre d'affaires donc
un bon bah on vous souhaite bonne chance
dans votre aventure entreprise
montréalaise qui existe depuis dix ans
merci madame madame merci au revoir